Guerry big the biggest confusion in
America in 2019 is that money is
happiness and I want people to be happy
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends until our society redefines
success and being happy not being rich
everybody will continue to go down the
path that we're seeing in our society of
depression anxiety drugs if for some way
through a joke or an analogy or a
conversation here today or an answer to
a question I can get you to start the
process of genuinely being able to
handle judgment because you finally are
exhausted exhausted of living your life
based on other people's opinions you
don't do things because somebody says
you're ugly or you're stupid in a
comment and you have no idea who they
are and they're hiding between an avatar
and some [ __ ] name over here all the
way to your mom
that that's what I spend all my time on
from this person to that person why is
that dictating you they think they're
doing the right thing because they
[ __ ] actually love their parents I
get it I love my parents so
uncomfortably much it's scares me but
they live it because they're appeasing
lawyer to kids living in this area
doing the job don't take risks as we
told you not to we came from a
generation that didn't so you're doing
that or I was once an entrepreneur and
[ __ ] it up and so we were scared so
now you don't do that they live for
their parents they think it's good cuz
everything's good cuz you're doing what
your parents want you feel like it's
good and what starts happening is they
start to respect their parents because
now they're popped into their 50th
birthday their 60th birthday their 65th
birthday they get a health scare and
they're like [ __ ] I'm not doing what I
want to be doing the question is why
like I'm just trying to get to why like
who my friends every person here that's
not a hundred percent happy including
myself is not doing something because of
judgment of somebody else you have to be
honest with yourself because if you're
incapable of that you have no prayer of
happiness and being honest with yourself
is hard it's not fun to say you suck
vulnerability is strength if you took a
step back and actually said what do I
[ __ ] like I'm trying to get people to
win I'm watching real deep sadness and
it's not because of social media social
media is not making you sad your
insecurities making you sad I love you
back my friends this is a [ __ ] game
you want to [ __ ] win in life fall in
love with losing because most people
here are scared of it the number one
unlock to happiness in this room is to
go out there after this talk and get
naked about your vulnerabilities what
you suck at take a step back go humble
this about losing and humility at the
and nobody's talking about it there's no
system you want to build something it's
hard working talent
hard work and talent what's gonna happen
is gonna post on YouTube and I'm gonna
read the comments they'll be like go
easy for him to say I'm rich but I'll
cry my Ferrari until you're crying in
your Ferrari and when you have money and
you're satisfied real bad [ __ ] happens
cuz that [ __ ] goes from cognac and lead
to cocaine and guns in your [ __ ]
mouth
my friends it is time once and for all
to [ __ ] cut the [ __ ] we need to
start talk about happiness by the way I
think I should only talk in New Jersey
right [ __ ] I'm not sure I want to
talk anywhere else the [ __ ] New
Jersey
I [ __ ] love you guys that's a real
[ __ ] I [ __ ] love you guys it's a real
[ __ ] on some real [ __ ] please take my
energy here today because it's on rare
form to get happy just get happy yo like
[ __ ]
[Music]